Toki's millet treats as more than 300
fighters have been captured or killed
the Kurds say it's actually 29 of their
fighters who have died but the UN is
also talking about the aerial strikes
and the shelling which has now displace
more than a hundred thousand people with
turkey capturing 15 villages and setting
up a military base at the border in the
past hour the u.s. Pentagon during that
briefing that you saw earlier was also
talking about Syria and insisted the US
is still fully supporting their Kurdish
allies but concern about American troops
is paramount rather than get pulled into
this conflict we put the welfare of our
soldiers first while urging Turkey to
forgo its operation and working hard
with us to address their concerns
through the development of a security
zone along the border we remain in close
coordination with the Syrian democratic
forces who helped us destroy the
physical Caliphate of Isis but I will
not place American servicemembers in the
middle of a long-standing conflict
between the Turks and the Kurds this is
not why we are in Syria we are not
waiting for terrorists to come to our
door we are now aiming to destroy terror
organizations at their source turkey
always respects the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of our neighbors
but under one condition
we are not going to accept actions
against our country sinem co-ceo news
with us now from Istanbul he is not
stepping back at all is he sin MD I
noticed that the two American officials
speaking earlier said that they felt
there was no backward Stefan and I guess
he's reiterating it there the president
well yes come on exactly he's not
stepping back but see everybody knew
that this was coming even when we
listened to the Pentagon officials a few
hours ago they were saying the same
thing Turkey was eager to do it if the
u.s. didn't do anything
mainly Adan said that the he talked to
US President Donald Trump and other
coalition members that if they don't
stop cooperating with the Syrian Kurdish
fighter group the YPG which Turkey sees
as the Syria branch of the outlawed
Kurdistan Workers Party Turkey would
take a unilateral action and he says
this is what we did you didn't do what
we told so we took a unilateral action
we took care of ourselves by ourselves
and we
will not stop it until the YPG moves 32
kilometers south of Turkey's border 32
kilometers is the designated area by
turkey for a possible safe zone in order
to send back some of the Syrians some of
the millions of Syrian refugees and
tricky but basically he mentioned that a
turkey would be sending sending back
almost 4 million Syrian refugees back to
this area so it seems turkey is not
going to stop this operation until
turkey gets that 30 kilometers deep of a
safe zone by its border because he said
that I don't said that turkey is
receiving threats by this organization
in Syria and also in Iraq that's why
turkey is conducting counter border
cross-border operations against this
organization which doesn't aim any any
harm to those countries territorial
integrity but it's been three days so
far despite NATO statements that the
turkeys security concerns towards the
YPG are legitimate still turkey doesn't
have much international support for this
operation but our Don seems well seems
not to stop but there is a perception
here in Turkey mainly in the Turkish
capital Ankara comma that US President
Donald Trump is dealing with domestic
politics and he's kind of stuck somehow
so so far it seems like the u.s. is
trying to give turkey two options they
say either you halt this operation or
you make peace with this with this
Kurdish group YPG which turkey is
totally against and in this press
conference Turkish president said that
Turkey will never make a peace with this
organization because the YPG is also
named as a traitor a betrayer by the
Syrian regime because yesterday Syrian
deputy foreign minister said that the
regime also is not thinking about any
dialogue with the YPG as they are a
separatist group and they they betrayed
Syria sinem concealed you with the
uptake from
instantl thank you seen him